just time for a visit to the big red  chair this is very exciting  okay first person in the red chair hello  hello what's your name  Celine hello Celine hi jack what story  have you got for us well this is my  second visit to the red chair actually  oh I was here 8 years ago right and I  told a story that I thought was really  good about when I was living in France  and something happened with my daughter  however a certain guest on the sofa that  night really did not like my story and  he was rather rude he actually said is  that the best story she could come up  with who does she bloody think she is  funnily enough my daughter met this  person at a nightclub recently oh my god  it's me  to actually watch him I sent you a  message didn't apologize I know I'm so  sorry  [Applause]  No  [Music]  you